so before today's video starts I want to
tell you guys that the reason why I've
not been uploading lately is because I
just moved houses and I did not have
internet so let's took a while for me to
be able to get that set up and also just
so you guys know I will be busy for the
next week and a half so I will not be
able to post a video but I will be
coming back and I will be trying to post
quite frequently at least three times a
week and I hope you guys understand and
let's get into the video what is up guys
so in today's video what we are going to
be doing we're going to be asking items
that will make you major profit so the
items that we are buying are the room to
H the room plate skirt room plate legs
alright I'll have to change that in a
sec green D hi bodies
g'head bodies ought to change that one
as well so these items all out for about
a profit of anywhere between 300 to 200
GP and sometimes you can get even more
if you put in an offer for even less and
let it sit overnight and you can make
even more
I believe the buy limit for the D hi
bodies is like just over 100 like 125
sometimes like 150 I don't remember
which ones have what buy limit but I
will leave that in the description and
the buy limit for the rune items I think
is 90 so if you buy these overnight then
you can easily make your money in the
morning and then rebuy them instantly
so if you want to do this hourly you
will have to buy them in advance so I
will go ahead and put them in the Alex
pot and I will go ahead and start a
timer and show yours how long it takes
the only annoying part about high-octane
high value items is that you have to
click the spacebar and they click one
because it asks you are you sure you
want to out this it doesn't mess up the
time but it is a little bit more
intensive because you do have to pay
attention a little bit more but it's
really not that big deal alright enjoy
watching me out I know it's not exciting
but I just wanted to prove to you guys
that I did do this for the full time and
I didn't mess up on the time and cheat
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so we're almost done alkene and
it's been about five minutes so I'm
gonna go ahead and calculate how much
money we'd make if this was done hourly
okay time to do the math so we use nine
th original times that by the 207 GP
that I paid for each one so 20,000 286
so write that down here so I can add
that to the total so the 760,000 of the
verne two H's plus the seven hundred
fifty nine thousand 120 from the room
plate skirts plus the seven hundred
sixty thousand again plus the eighty
seven thousand five hundred and
six hundred eighty three thousand two
hundred eight so now we will add the
twenty thousand two hundred eighty six
from the nature and so three mil twenty
five thousand 114
I'm honest buddy so I'm going to go
ahead and check what I hide out them for
so the green D hi bodies 4680 so times
20 I'm doing these calculations
off-screen so I can look at both but
ninety two thousand six hundred nine run
plate skirts that I bought so
8400 times 18 it looks like both of
these are the same hi alkalis so 600 I
knew 1,200 okay and you head down that I
need to type it in down here not up
there so now the rune plate legs or the
plate skirts are the same so 38 thousand
four hundred times
twenty seven hundred sixty-eight
thousand plus seven hundred sixty-eight
thousand again kids of the same price
now the room to H I think it's the same
price yep 38,400 again so 768 thousand
and now we'll need to add all these up
so ninety-two thousand six hundred plus
six hundred ninety one thousand two
hundred
+7 under 68,000
I will just keep adding these so three
million eighty eight thousand eight
hundred so now we'll need to minus the
other number from how much it cost so we
made sixty three thousand six hundred
eighty six and five minutes 60 divided
by five is twelve times twelve so seven
hundred sixty-four thousand if you did
this hourly so if you bought these in
advance you can make almost eight
hundred K in an hour that is insane
thanks guys for watching and stay tuned
for the next video
[Music]